okay in a similar way like the opposite
of question is a product right so I have
product identities okay I'm gonna run
out of space I might need my lost
hexagon over their product identities
instead of going around I can put things
to get enough okay I can put things
together so for instance here we go this
this have a look at that do you see
what's happening
Ted put together with cause if you put
them together let's write this wrong
wrong comma 10 x cos x that's sine all
in clause times cos which is just Sarge
right so if I put tan and close together
I'll get sine I pointed to go anywhere
else you like if I put scient iams
SEC sine times sec I'm going to get tan
right because what's SEC again
remind me what SEC is it's one of our
cause so sine times whatever cause is
sine on cause it's ten so you get
anywhere around here and put things
together caught times set will give you
co SEC okay
you can even go right through the middle
of the circle this is the same as their
reciprocals right I can take for
instance because they're reciprocals
cause times set will give you one
because they're reciprocals okay bye
so there are some products a few more to
show you remember that's what we started
with right we're looking at arm when you
shift things back and forth these ones
are called the complementary identities
the complimentary item is now
complimentary you remember when it
refers to angles means two angles that
add eternity so four is ins forty and
fifty thirty and sixty 27 and 63 these
are complementary angles right and
there's a bunch of trigger that is to go
with those right so that most basic one
is sine X is equal to cos of degrees -
names make you see that the way I read
that is I go straight across so I got
sine x equals this is going to be the
complement and I can really in reverse
as well cos x is going to be sine of 90
degrees - etchant go in the other
direction
but if you have a looking we follow this
pattern I can do this down here as well
look all the way across I have another
complementary up then anything right 10
X is equal to sine of sorry its clutch
should do the next line it's cut off 90
degrees to minus X can you see why you
see why it's based on this line up here
what's quite it's what's on the radar
it's cause of sine right cause on the
side so it's cos 90 minus X on sine 90
minus X aha but I know what both of
these are both of these right that's
sine and and that's cause on the
denominator which is what I was
expecting
right son okay and one last one because
I've gone this way across I've gone this
way across SEC X is equal to cosec over
90 minus X or vice versa okay and you
don't prove it to yourself in exactly
the same we've got reciprocals quotients
products which is really the same thing
in Reverse I've got these complimentary
identities here for today the last time
I'm going to show you are a special one
what approve
okay so I'll make this face here
underneath where all your hexagons are
you'll need this last one but I'd also
like you to draw a small unit circle for
me a small unit circle yes
okay so here's my unit circle right
I should chew questions and you know the
answers to both of these already but as
yet most of you at least have not put
these two answers together and this is
one of the coolest things about maths
when you look at one theme from two
different angles and you often yield an
insight okay so first question we're
looking at unit circle because we've
defined causes sine as a point on the
circumference of the unit circle any way
you like right so what are the
coordinates of any given point if like
angle theta there or the coordinates of
the point in terms of the trig functions
it's alphabetical
so it's cos and then son that was my
next guess okay there you go all right
so there are my coordinates okay all
right another question this is the unit
circle go back to Cartesian land go stop
the Catrin option for a second in
Cartesian live what's the equation of
this circle it's just a circle x squared
plus y squared equals the radius squared
which in this case is 1 okay
Oh hold on a second what is it we've
defined X as cos theta and we've defined
y as sine theta all the way around so if
I just do a straight substitution of
this into this I yield this
don't know I've just put cause we're
exes and I put aside where why is I do
right close Peter all squared in a bit
of a funny way what this really means is
this which I think's I have you have
seen this before
but it's been an awkward way to write it
and sometimes people leave off the
brackets and then they confuse it with
this and those are quite different
things okay so we kind of use this
shorthand so this is cos theta or
squared sine theta
all squared equals one all I'm doing is
putting these together but you can see
it it works really obviously let's just
take it with some numbers that you know
the exact values for right let's try say
C equals 30 equals 30 degrees okay cos
theta cos 30 root three on two so this
is going to be root 3 on two swear right
sine 30 uh-huh square what's that that's
going to be 3/4 that's gonna be 1/4 BAM
try it again try it for 60 try it for 45
will do it for 45 just because it's so
simple right
cos theta and sine theta for 45 degrees
I'll first the same I think what I like
1 over 2 so I'm going to get 1 on root 2
squared plus 100 2 squared that's a ha
ha that's one it's one it's always gonna
be one because every are in the unit
circle x squared plus y squared equals
one that's the different unit so okay
this is an identity right this is an
important thing because I can see in a
right angle triangle right if I just
draw this for you clearly where a cause
inside
causes here scientists here there's one
and Pythagoras tells you cos squared
plus sine squared in a right angle
triangle is one squared right it's the
same thing because you get it from
Pythagoras this is often cold
the Pythagorean identity right
reciprocals quotients products
complementary this one this is the
plastic origin but there's more than one
so I'm going to save through I'm gonna
change back to my normal so here's my
default right cos squared plus sine
squared equals one or of course I could
write sine squared plus cos squared I
can get from this to two other forms of
the same thing by just dividing through
by something convenient so for instance
other three times here if I divide every
single one by cos squared what happens
this is the easy one it becomes 1 by
divide sine squared by closed squared I
get ten square and then if I divide one
by cos square I'm just getting the
reciprocal right which is C right
okay that was what happened when I
divided by sine squared sorry cos
squared so now let's try divided by sine
squared what's this going to turn into
when I divide by science what's this
gonna take what what's this going to
turn into sex with okay so these are the
Pythagorean identities I can shift them
all around in my life for instance see
there's top one I could subtract either
of these and put them on the other side
and it'd be the same identity cos
squared is 1 minus sine squared or I
could rearrange it a whole number of
different ways okay
but they're all the same identity okay
now ready to see the hexagon at work
what's this okay I was doing lines like
around and back and forth this one
you're gonna need something a little
more sophisticated way I remember is
it's about triangles right triangles so
what's this sine squared plus cos
squared it was one like a next one tan
squared plus one
was sex squared one more time 1 plus cos
squared is cosine squared or of course
you could go in reverse as well SEC
squared minus 1 is tense man 1 minus cos
squared and so easy